hello reject nation hime grek tomjohn
we're gonna watch today from our
favorite channel apparently WatchMojo
top 10 production nightmares you see
guys over at our patreon we do
full-length TV show reactions and weekly
Q&A s one of the reward tiers though
whatever video you request we must
definitely do it's usually a reaction
and that's a-ok in my book and today
comes from a man named Cameron French
now for the longest time Cameron French
has been pledged to her patreon in fact
one of our highest pledges but never
really heard a peep out of the guy and
lately we've actually been talking after
eight months in the making
we have finally started to carry on a
conversation fan out a couple facts
about him for one it was his birthday
very recently we pretty much shared the
same birthday we're like a day apart or
something it's a happy birthday to you
buddy
we love you say hi to all of Florida for
us I want to give a very sincere shout
out because I know you were going
through a rough time and that's why we
weren't really talking to us so I just
wanted to say to you keep that penis
intact
yeah don't damage if you want to get
through a hard time
give yourself a hard time
[Music]
stay the course for this place concept
problems quite the scandal tiny
externality clashes
to more serious troubles like injury
number ten
Waterworld filming in water is
notoriously difficult so a
post-apocalyptic sci-fi flick set
entirely in water might have problems
what do you say Toby the truth looks
like [ __ ] Waterworld was played from day
one
a hurricane's represent Kevin Costner
almost died on storm jellyfish kept
spinning mattresses wasn't stunt double
that's lost at sea when its jet ski ran
out of orbit 10 another almost died
filming underwater
director camera video this fire quick
before production was done leaving
Costner's are finished Waterworld
himself a whopping seventy five million
really great Universal attract
George Miller's Waterworld
[Music]
[Music]
this movie was cursed sure the original
set burned down but director William
temperatures to create atmosphere and
used unconventional techniques to get
the performances he wanted you really
twist that girl's head slap one actor
and shot a gun to startle another Ellen
Burstyn suffered Arctic damage or Fox
action after her harness was pulled too
hard
Oh John Allen died of the flu shortly
after filming they worked on this movie
and this one seems true number eight
Cleopatra we love it at the moment son
daughter to Isis the first producer
bailed at five male over budget with
nothing to show for it
Elizabeth Taylor reporter a life-saving
tracheotomy during filming delaying
things further
thanks working a move London to Rome
which meant all sets needed to be
rebuilt by God
she also started a toured and public
affair with co-star Richard Burton Oh
Mitch cause
unwanted publicity finally finished
after two and a half years but it had no
hope of earning back its exorbitant
production costs number seven oh you
like every Marlon Brando star Val Kilmer
but with everyone leading to the
dismissal of director Richard Stanley in
favor of John Frankenheimer they didn't
get along much better then actor Rob
moreover wait cuz it strictly rights and
true to form Marlon Brando didn't feel
like learning his lines so he got them
through an earpiece judge not mr.
Douglas did he be not judged by these
judgments as he olds will be judged and
that he will have up sin cast the first
stone but he was also dealing with
personal issues after learning that his
daughter had committed suicide not a
great experience for anyone involved
rages spectacle I have ever witnessed
number 6 its Corrado screenwriter
director Verner Hertzog had a particular
vision for this film and moving a 320
ton steamship wasn't going to stop him
the barristers are going to have to
touch jaws from I mean Helle you're
going to do that he pursed his crew to
reminisce ownership of a steep hill
leading to three injuries that slope may
look insignificant but it's gonna be our
destiny the original star Jason Robards
got sick halfway through filming so
hurts doc hard Klaus Kinski an actor
with whom he had previously clashed
violently during
a beginner the wrath of God he's been
dead song Hutus that's cool that he
their second partnership fared no better
and an extra even offered to kill Kinski
number punished John's a shark
Sharky without wearing it performance at
the movie and he didn't even without a
finished script usually doesn't bode
well for the rest of the production
you've got any better suggestions
Spielberg wanted the script to diverge
from Peter Benchley's novel which led to
multiple rewrites he's very smart very
dumb he also had trouble casting the
film as it was turned down by Hollywood
heavyweights like Robert Duvall and John
Boyd on top of big shark no it's cool
couldn't get the shark to work Robert
Shaw disliked Richard Dreyfuss and the
shoot went 100 days over schedule Wow
Titanic was close had nightmares
James Cameron has a reputation for
perfectionism
in fact he was nicknamed the scariest
man in Hollywood after her long fall
besides being grossly over budget
Cameron was tough on the crew as they
moved around his titanic replica and
cold water temperatures an issue he also
had on the abyss I know how alone you
feel alone so bad one crew member spiked
a dinner with PCP never heard that's a
reason illnesses aside Titanic
Cameron king of the world
one more thing I can tell this story
we're gonna say that for the reaction
number three Apocalypse Now oh yeah
production wrapped after 16 grueling
months that skyrocketed the film's
budget making Apocalypse Now was an
uphill battle in which Francis Ford
Coppola dealt with unpredictable weather
like hurricanes and typhoons that
destroyed his set what his past was no
picnic either he replaced Harvey Keitel
with Martin Sheen who later had a heart
attack on set whoa I know that no no
that
[Music]
set up an order next to us veteran actor
Marlon Brando showed up overweight and
underprepared for service forcing
Coppola to rewrite much of his dialogue
and threaten suicide several times
[Music]
number two the chrome Oh God unlike the
other productions on our list filming
for this movie went relatively smoothly
until a fatal accident led to the death
of star Brandon Lee due to mishandling
of the props and improper gun safety
knowledge
Lee was shot in the stomach by a prop
gun with basically the same force as a
real bullet was mortally wounded and
died hours later my me was greeted to
finish his scenes
really
and the song can't rest before we unveil
our number-one hit here are honorable
men G honorable mention isn't there any
way off of this place it's also suck to
make a rush it comes every six months
that's it I came into this game for the
action the excitement go anyway travel
oh yeah and to get out of this trouble
man alone now they got the whole country
sectioned off you can't make a move
without a form that you Honorable
Mention give no information to ya
whenever you come in here and interrupt
me you're breaking my concentration just
[Music]
number one
hmm scare me are you ready twilit yeah
really uh-huh
really what are you doing you know I've
never actually seen this movie Twilight
Zone the movie oh wait yeah people's
right yeah pyrotechnics used for special
effects cost a real-life helicopter
crash to occur during John Landis's time
code segment you know and unfortunately
the crash was fatal for actor Vic Morrow
as well as to illegally hired child
extras this country was rated talked
about
for ten years afterward the filmmakers
were involved in civil and criminal
cases connected to the tragedy but
ultimately Landis and his team were
found not guilty of manslaughter
once you come over here cheer me up I
needed you agree with our list I think
they're 19 what happened on turn sounded
like the biggest you be sure to
subscribe to watchmojo.com you know it's
funny about looking over this list you
hear production nightmare stories and
sometimes you get an amazing film out of
that and sometimes it greatly affects
your moment if he's such a bad world
it's weird certain films like Apocalypse
Now you're like having that kind of
tension on set seems like you would
totally add to everything and something
like Waterworld that's so hypothetical
and probably relies on so many special
effects I can totally see how this
tanked because of all those problems
especially having to switch directors
all I know is that water roll was a big
flop I don't know any of this [ __ ] about
the girl getting stung by jellyfish
first getting lost at sea
I was like did they go back for Kevin
costs or having to finish the film
himself I've heard Kevin Costner can be
a rough guy to work with at least at the
time in chemi-con was hot I've heard
Kevin Costner was a rough guy he's
calmed down since he started playing pot
can yeah man I heard these stories about
the Exorcist of is it you noticed
whether the set essentially being cursed
I didn't know about some of the injuries
some of these actors suffer how insanely
methodical the director might be with
his approach to get real reactions
sometimes on horror movies that can be
fun when you hear something behind the
scenes like I remember hatchet they
really worked hard on making sure you
can get
reactions out of the actors so like they
never met the guy was playing Victor
Crowley
there wasn't one shower they like threw
an axe but they told the actor there was
a relaxes I did stuff to like freak them
out yeah but then you get stuff like The
Exorcist too far yeah it's fun to assert
if you're making people jump or whatever
like that's one thing it's like fire a
real gun and really slap someone and all
those things and there's some terrible
yes stories across multiple movies about
directors wanting things to be real and
that going wrong yeah I mean you know
this video is kind of old but I mean
Last Tango in Paris to me I refuse to
watch that movie that's an impressive
store all the stuff I know about that
film but with the Exorcist one thing
they didn't mention that I learned very
recent is who plays the girl Linda Blair
Linda Blair Linda Hamilton Linda
Hamilton Linda Blair they had to hire
personal security team for her for six
months following the film's release
because of how much harassment she was
receiving for participating in this role
Catholic churches or whatever thought
she might have been you know really
satanic I forget what the actual details
are I love that compassion we're gonna
attack you yeah
because of this work of fiction we don't
agree with yeah Cleopatra man I had no
idea about any of that stuff
I'm not surprised like most of what I
knew about Cleopatra beforehand was just
how like Hercule in a production it was
especially for old Hollywood where they
really just built everything have real
actions of extras yes Ben Hur had
similar problems mm-hmm yeah I'm
supposed to mention been hurt all here
because I'm surprised he didn't just
mention every epic of this variety or
even Howard Hughes's first film
complains yeah you've seen the Aviator
you know what everyone wrong on the
future yeah a lot of those old Hollywood
films because they didn't have CGI back
then and they were still making the
mistakes that would lead to future
regulations
yeah that's pretty surprising cuz you
could have kind of clumped a lot of old
Hollywood films in this one category
right here they said like there was no
way they can make its money back it's a
classic right that's an epic classic oh
yeah and over time it must have made its
money back inflation and things like
that I maybe not if
effectively in their lifetimes like the
key players lifetimes perhaps but I
can't imagine it's made it's perfect
yeah I wanted dr. Monroe is a famously
messed up production
oh and dude anything with Marlon Brando
is essentially a messed up yeah I get
the sense there's a documentary I've
heard a ton about about this movies like
yeah the original guy was supposed to
make it like went undercover as one of
the creatures and like documented the
experience oh really it's kind of weird
for this movie too because of how insane
the behind-the-scenes was on this and
then you even think about what the movie
is - yeah feeling about it yeah it
doesn't help
Waterworld so much but for a movie like
this for me it kind of increases that
level of morbid curiosity or I'm like I
want to see what this spectacular mess
wound up being yeah I watch Guys and
Dolls the other day and I just decided
to look up the film and then it led to a
whole like is everything part of the
prank it was time and he's just
notoriously known for causing problems
on pretty much every movie set he's ever
been a part of you know even in his
younger before he it's like he got worse
the fatter he got it's the price of
greatness but even before that it was
pretty hard guy to work with for sure
that whole thing with him not wanting to
remember his lines or have it fed
through an earpiece or some people hold
up cue cards for him I think on Superman
they had to hold up cards for him he'll
be the highest-paid guy on set but the
least prepared dude ever and still walk
away with Oscar nominations because he's
that good he was all about like craft
and Method like wouldn't you want to get
off-book I think he's great at letting
go and just doing his job
you know I feel like he was just one of
those mysteriously great actors like
Apocalypse Now he shows up on set in
France where I was like what the hell is
going on I have to rewrite this whole
thing and then he gets an Oscar
nomination above Martin Sheen he is the
author yeah I know of it I gotta watch
more Hertzog movies but I have heard
that this was kind of a legendarily if
that's a word troubled production - I
mean that looks like one of those movies
especially when it's like roughing it
and trailblazing and like doing a
physical journey of some kind any of
those like period movies
always seem like they would be very
grueling especially when you have a
director like Hertzog who wants to get
into the real [ __ ] yeah whenever I
watched those kind of movies or even
like looking at platoon which could have
been on this list to really excruciating
to make or office I watched roediger
again really or anything in like that
story of he didn't get along with this
guy he hires again like you know I know
that you're good for the troubled
production so why don't you join me for
this [ __ ] show
I've never heard of anything going that
way with director and actor before never
I'm like if David O'Russell just kept
working with Lily Tomlin jaws yeah I
mean you go on the universal tour I
they'll tell you about how the shark
never worked that's just what they go
it's got a rich you know it wasn't
mentioned here but I believe Roy cider
and Steven Spielberg didn't get along
either fact check me John the rumor I
heard was that the reason Spielberg
didn't return for Jaws 2 was because
they had to choose between the star or
director oh that's him or me
I'm not entirely sure about that I mean
I could see why they would go with a
star overspill burg at that time to save
money especially considering how
over-budget this film went in over
production time like yeah it's something
insane right I could see whether like
we're not bringing this guy back you
know but it seems like jaws might have
benefited from bringing back Spielberg
instead mm-hmm
I just feel really sorry for Robert Shaw
because he gives the best performance in
the whole movie yeah like that's a
legendary there's even a lot of locals
on the boat finds you and reenact that
monologue speak for that I think you
died before the film was released really
unfortunate
Titanic man the one thing I know that
wasn't mentioned here was there would be
scenes where they're in the water and
Cameron would just yell at them if they
had to go to the bathroom just be like
just pee in the water like go to the
water like that's so gross oh my god I'm
not gonna know
no I do it don't worry there are tons of
fish peeing in the water like set water
for real Oh disgusting yeah I'm not
gonna I'm shooting my home they drained
it on the daily or something cuz yeah
it's funny cuz kate winslet said she
would never work with him ever again
and now she's an avatar - I've read
something where they put aside their
differences forever it's in her contract
that there are no water scene this
yesterday was really it's funny because
what I've heard about the directing
styles with actors James Cameron and
Michael pace have very similar except
one turns out it doesn't take raw talent
to be a perfectionist the crow la people
might not know this man but my childhood
movies who were the crow and then scream
crow came out when I was like three or
something then we release dates 94 93
something like that I like adored this
movie so much I think it was the first
graphic novel I read because how much I
loved the movie and hearing that story
broke my heart and this is true fact
about me however old I was in third
grade I made a birthday wish that
Brandon leave a few resurrected from the
tip maybe it worked because I wanted to
make my own predator movie and Evan
sorry when I hear the pitch for that
movie now hey Topher was imprinted yours
alright really whatever I was watching
at that age movies and Matt LeBlanc
could have been cool to pray he did it
was a should have been pretty much all
the male cast of friends very sex is
good chicks can't fight the predator you
don't need a Rachel in there what's
weird - is that scene occurs
wait before the finale in the movie -
and it's kind of crazy how much that
movie still flows really well and it
space really well must have been one of
the later scenes they shot because I've
never been able to really tell when it's
not really I'm sure if I watched it now
I could tell this scene is not towards
the end of the movie it's pretty early
on and the scenes complete to the whole
scenes done I was always astonished by
that too because as tragic as everything
is I guess it's theoretically lucky for
that movie that they had most of his
principal stuff I guess shot yeah I the
time it happened but every time I see
the crow it feels so tangible you're
like if you could just go back and fix
that one moment everything could be
different and we could have a whole
career you know I feel sorry for that
guy because it wasn't his fault
yeah of course you know because he was a
guy pulled the trigger yeah when you
think about that story makes the movies
like John wick yeah looking like
terrifying
I mean you gotta get like action-packed
gun-toting movie after that I got
imagine people are a little like I've
actually never seen The Twilight Zone
movies it's on my list of films that I
get crap or not saying I've not seen it
ever in one sitting but I feel like I've
seen all the segments horst serious
stories or when they're for horror
movies I mean most of these are not
horror movies yeah something kind of
have a horror element to them Apocalypse
Now has as horror elements oh yeah
Titanic is a terrifying elements to it
jaws you know a lot of these a lot of
these movies have their horror elements
to him but when it's like straight-up a
horror type of movie like Twilight Zone
that's pretty terrifying yeah you're
about the production that's why I've
demonic kind of horror movies freaked me
out in general completely like see see
kinda realism a thing actually working
at blum house we would run a lot of
those kinds of stories and apparently
like The Omen Rosemary's Baby the
exercise like so many prominent demon
and haunting movies had reportedly
haunted or cursed sets were like lots of
people died either in mysterious
happenings or on set right and this is
one of the worst I mean like III had
heard about the actor and in the head
I didn't know there were two
unauthorized child extras yeah like
that's horrific
I mean it's already horrific but that's
like even more I remember like John
Landis I know it like affected his
career for at least a while like he kind
of you know I mean this videos from 2014
am a third of these list comes because I
think there's another one of these
there's like a follow but when the third
one comes out that's definitely gonna be
yeah there's so many here Oh buddy
that's fascinating too because yeah like
the thin line between when you can use
that complication that frustration for
the benefit of the movie and when it
just do rails and everything well I feel
like especially in the times we're
living in now we get way more stories of
production nightmares not not like fun
stories some of these are like whoa
that's kind of fun to put on this list
what not all of them but some of them
are with the movements we've had we get
a lot more stories because things are
also usually safer now too so it's less
like weird occurrences or happenstance
and more just people behaving poorly in
one direction or another and everyone's
got a phone now all the mics are on man
all right I mean that was a fun video
thanks Cameron guys called oh thank you
so much for watching please go check out
our patreon full-length TV show
reactions and q and A's and other
goodies you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation subscribe to watchmojo.com
to watch them click notification bells
all around just do it